[Musik]
schönen guten tag zu einem die richtigen
fragen spezial mit dem mann der
deutschland bald verlassen wird andré
wenig bisherige botschafter hier in
berlin hermeling wie lange haben sie
noch hier
guten tag herr runzheimer danke für die
einladung es bleiben mir einige wochen
das datum steht noch nicht fest aber wir
sind gerade beim backen wissen sie schon
was dann passiert was in kiew auf die
zukunft werden sie tatsächlich
vize-außenminister wie es geißler also
ich würde das vielleicht noch nicht
kommentieren aber
solange die entscheidung noch nicht
getroffen wurde und diese entscheidung
trifft die regierung und deswegen würde
ich das noch nicht spekulieren aber ich
bereite ich mich vor weiterhin im
diplomatischen dienst zu bleiben und
auch für die ukraine zu kämpfen war das
jetzt aus ihrer sicht eine abberufung
weil man wütend in kiew oder war das
alles ganz normal nach acht jahren
ich glaube
acht jahre oder fast acht jahre
siebeneinhalb jahren die hier verbringen
durfte und dafür bin ich dankbar nicht
nur den präsidenten aber auch dem
schicksal und dem lieben gott dass ich
hier überhaupt in deutschland arbeiten
durfte eine lange zeit und meine
abberufung gehört auch zu diesem
geschäft normalerweise es gilt dieses
rotationsprinzip und deswegen früher
oder später kehrt man nach hause und ich
bin froh auch wieder ähnliche zusagen
jetzt gelten sie ja so als der
undiplomatische diplomat aller zeiten
kann man sagen sie haben deutschland
viel kritisiert vor allem die regierung
mich würde interessieren was lieben sie
eigentlich an deutschland
also wir lieben deutschland als land wir
lieben die menschen wir lieben die
kultur
andererseits
werden wir gar nicht hier gewesen also
das war eine bewusste entscheidung das
war ein traumjob von mir auch meine
familie hat mich unterstützt mitgemacht
alleine kann man das gar nicht stemmen
und deswegen fällt auch dieser abschnitt
ehrlich gesagt uns ziemlich schwer wenn
sie jetzt zurück schauen auf die letzten
monate an welchen politiker an welches
regierungsmitglied erinnern sie sich
besonders auf wen sind sie am meisten
sind
ja so ist kommt ja nicht darauf an ob
man auf jemanden würden wir erwarten
hier
entscheidungen die uns helfen sollen den
krieg zu beenden die aggressionen ab zu
werden und wenn wir sehen dass diese
entscheidungen wochen oder sogar monate
lang verzögert werden dann müssen wir
die stimme erheben dann müssen wir auch
manchmal kritisieren jetzt waren sie so
ein bisschen unruhig in den letzten
monaten der alte wenig was würde heute
sagen was braucht die ukraine momentan
besonders und was läuft momentan schief
aus ihrer sicht weil es sind ja immer
noch nicht besonders viele war von aus
deutschland in der ukraine angekommen
und das ewige thema
waffenlieferungen es gab in den letzten
wochen gottseidank einige entscheidungen
die wir begrüßen
mehrfach raketenwerfer drei zusätzliche
panzerhaubitzen wurden geliefert aber
sonst ist beim thema oder sind wir beim
thema ringtausch kein zentimeter voran
gekommen auch was
die band so angeht ja das thema steht ja
und er liegt auf dem tisch seien viele
kanzlermehrheit hinaus sehen dass ich
leopard marder das ist ja in der
diskussion unter scholz will die nicht
direkt liefern glauben sie das wird sich
ändern braucht die ukraine diese panzer
ist auf jeden fall also leopard 1 und
schützenpanzer marder das ist das was
die industrie schon seit märz hätte
liefern können und zwar schrittweise das
ist bis heute nicht geschehen dann grund
können wir uns leider nicht erklären es
gibt ja keinen grund ist dass kanzler
scholz weiter also wir glauben dass das
die entscheiden und nach wie vor im
kanzleramt getroffen werden muss sonst
wissen wir dass
andere ministerien diesem wunsch seit
monaten eigentlich sehr positiv
gegenüber stehen und deswegen können wir
die leute kriegt verstehen dass die
deutschen nicht als erster diesen
schritt machen das nur wenn die
amerikaner die arbeit als panzer liefern
sollten dann wäre warum es sich hier um
salat scholz hat immer noch angst vor
platte wir pro 10.000 atomschlag kommen
könnt also das ist uns leider bis heute
und gründlich muss man schon sagen denn
es gibt ja keine logik und flac gepard
banzer zu liefern aber nicht 1 oder 2
oder auch zum beispiel
fuchs-transportpanzer das alles werde
mögliche auch die bundeswehr wäre in der
lage durchaus das zu tun und wir
brauchen gerade jetzt diese
waffensysteme um diese offensive im
süden kaesong zu befreien um diese
offensive voranzubringen man braucht
gerade da auch diese schützenpanzer und
zwar hunderte der von deutschland wär da
durchaus in der lage das zu tun ohne
sich quasi zu entwaffnen das wäre ja
keine ausplünderung jetzt hat man das
gefühl die stimmung schlägt bereits um
in deutschland gerade was die sanktionen
angeht die debatte um gas wir haben uns
umgehört in berlin was die menschen über
die sanktion denken
das ist ein schwachsinn hoch ziehen die
sanktionen treffen uns und nicht
russland also wenn ich jemanden
sanktionieren möchte dann muss ich das
auch so machen dass derjenige den ich
versuche zu sanktionieren dass auch
merkt und im moment merken wir doch nur
die sanktionen und russland lacht sich
tot sie verkaufen ihr gast was sie uns
vorher mit günstigen zu günstigen
konditionen verkauft hätten verkaufen
die jetzt teurer woanders hin und wir
verkaufen zur not noch viel teurer oder
wir kaufen zur not noch viel teurer
wieder also wie schwachsinniger kann man
es nicht machen also ich sehe dass wir
uns mit den sagt sie und ruinieren als
dass wir russland damit wesentlich
schaden hier hat das merken der erna
hand der enormen preissteigerungen im
bereich der energie das merken wir an
anderen preissteigerungen im bereich der
lebensmittel es geht ja die inflation
rasant in die jugend ich denke dass erst
der anfang weil der krieg von der nato
mindestens genauso zu verantworten ist
von russland wenig wenn man das hört
machen sich sorgen was ist die antwort
an diese menschen die sagen die dann zum
bringen nichts also wir können die
sorgen der einfachen deutschen sehr wohl
verstehen dass sie sich dass sie angst
haben ob sie ihre gasrechnungen bezahlen
können andererseits glauben wir schon da
die sanktionen notwendig und richtig
sind sie entfalten ihre wirkung erst
mittel oder langfristig und dann müsste
man auch diese strategische geduld haben
und für die menschen was kann ich sagen
es tut uns leid also die regierung oder
die vorherigen regierungen hier haben
deutschland selbst in diese schwierige
lage hineinmanövriert und jetzt müsse
auch die bundesregierung wirklich diese
führungskraft zeigen die menschen
mitnehmen also nicht weiter die angst
und panik streuen sondern wirklich die
menschen überzeugt die regierung panik
aus ihrer sicht habe der workshops alle
reden nur noch über gast sie versuchen
eine lösung zu finden diese schwer
fallen wird denn dieser diese
abhängigkeit deutschlands von russland
ist massive und natürlich macht sich
auch die regierung sorgen inwieweit die
industrie diesen schock überleben kann
aber aus meiner sicht es ist durchaus
möglich auch die menschen hier zu
beruhigen und zu sagen das hat auch der
ganze bekannt aber die stimmung kippt
ist das auch ihr eindruck you never walk
alone also dass das war glaube ich ein
ein guter satz des kanzlers aber jetzt
müsse auch jeder satz mit mit leben
gefüllt werden damit die menschen auch
spüren und sehen ja sie sind nicht
alleine auch in dieser schwierigen zeit
denn sie wird noch dauern das wird noch
monatelang dauern vielleicht auch jahre
welche dieser krieg vorbei ist und das
heißt da muss man wirklich diese geduld
aufbringen sie sprechen den krieg an
herrlich wenn sie eher zurückgehen nach
kiew im diplomatischen dienst da gibt es
einige die gesagt haben wenn es so weit
sein sollte wenn es notwendig sein
sollte
geht man an die front vitali klitschko
zum beispiel gesagt er würde wenn es
hart auf hart kommt sich verteidigen mit
der waffe gegen russland sind sie bereit
auch an die front zu gehen persönlich
ich bin offizier der reserve ich habe
zwar nicht gedient aber das ist etwas
was auf jeden man auch jetzt auch viele
frauen zu kommen kann und es würde mich
freuen auch waffentraining ausbildung zu
machen wenn wenn die zeit dass in kiew
erlauben würde dann um zu kämpfen muss
man wirklich auch mit der waffe umgehen
können das aber ist kein leid an die
front zuversichtlich ich bin also wenn
wenn das von mir erfordert würde
erfolgen würde wenn die lage der massen
brenzlig sein wird dass es keine andere
wahl wird dann dann wird es auch keine
war keine alternative mehr übrig bleiben
wenn wir noch mal ein bisschen
zurückschauen die letzte vor allem das
letzte jahr gibt es da eine aussage die
sie im nachhinein bereuen würden
ja es gibt vieles sehr vieles was was
gesagt wurde durch emotionen ausgelöst
und dass ich heute vielleicht in der
form nicht wiederholen würde aber
beleidigte leberwurst zum beispiel ich
hab' ich hab' ich habe schon gesagt dass
diese haus und auch stolz immer noch
eine beleidigte leberwurst ich habe
gesagt dass dieser ausdruck vielleicht
nicht ganz angemessen war und ich habe
gesagt dass ich bereit wäre wenn wenn
der ganze mich empfangen würde vor dem
abschied ich habe diesen termin
angefragt dann würde ich mich bei ihm
entschuldigen glauben sie empfängt sie
mal sehen also ich hoffe dass das das
gehört zumindest so zum guten ton wenn
jemand weg geld das er auch empfangen
wird ich habe vielleicht ab und zu
angeeckt aber mein
hauptwunsch und bleibt und ist die
beziehungen mit deutschland zu stärken
auch wenn das vielleicht nicht immer so
ausgesehen hat aber manchmal war es um
zumindest mein eindruck dass es
notwendig war
auch die stimme lauter zu machen und
vielleicht auch zu
kritisieren denn ohne ohne das wäre
glaube ich auch die deutsche
gesellschaft auch die deutsche
öffentlichkeit vielleicht oder hätte
nicht ganz begriffen den ernst der
stunde gestolpert sind sie jetzt nicht
über beschimpfungen deutscher politiker
sondern tatsächlich darüber dass sie den
ukrainischen nationalisten stepan
bandera verteidigt haben und ihn als
freiheitskämpfer gelobt haben bereuen
sie das im nachhinein ich bereue dass
das dieses interview und dann auch all
die kommentare eine welle der entrüstung
ausgelöst haben und das bei vielen
menschen auch in polen oder in israel
auch in deutschland gefühle verletzt
werden konnten also das bereue ich auf
jeden fall denn das war ja nicht mein
wunsch menschen vor den kopf zu stoßen
oder
auch glauben sie dass sie deshalb gehen
mussten ich glaube dass ich glaube dass
es
diese aussagen wahrscheinlich auch eine
rolle gespielt haben können dass das das
weiß ich nicht ich kann das nur vermuten
und
deswegen das zeigt auch dass bei manchen
themen vor allem die mit geschichte eng
verbunden sind vor allem das wort die
historiker übernehmen sollten und nicht
und nicht politiker und diplomaten
viele menschen auch in deutschland
fragen sich wie lange wird dieser krieg
noch dauern manche sagen jahre andere
sagen hoffentlich gibt es irgendwann
friedensverhandlungen haben sie
irgendwelche hoffnungen dass es
friedensverhandlungen geben könnte und
das ist ihre prognose wie lange wird
dieser krieg dauern und wer gewinnt
also die ukraine wird auf jeden fall
gewinnen also da besteht kein zweifel
dass zwei fest in welchen preis man
dafür
zu sagen hat und dieser preis hängt auch
davon ab ob die bundesregierung aber
auch andere westlichen partner und
gerade jetzt in dieser kritischen phase
unterstützen und deswegen zu spekulieren
wie lange die krise noch dauert werde
auch schwierig ich befürchte dass das
noch monate lang gehen wird aber
auch von berlin hängt ab ob wir diesen
krieg gemeinsam und das können wir nur
mit schweren waffen aber auch mit
modernen mit mit präzisionswaffen zu
ende führen und putin in die schranken
weisen und deswegen muss ich wieder
immer wieder auch vor dem abschnitt an
die bundesregierung appellieren wird es
gibt noch so viel dass das getan werden
kann hier in deutschland um uns zu
helfen und wir hoffen nach wie vor dass
man diese hilfe uns nicht verwehrt und
nicht verzögert herzlichen dank an
remake immer noch botschafter in der in
berlin aber bald zurück in care vielen
vielen dank und alles gute ihnen hier
und denke
ja dass also die richtigen fragen an den
bisherigen botschafter der ukraine hier
in deutschland andere wenig eine frage
haben wir noch hinten dran hennig wir
berichten hier den ganzen tag großes
thema in der welt heute die gezielte
tötung des
al-kaida-führers al-sawahiri in kabul
und im netz sofort die frage auf wenn
man dazu fähig ist die amerikaner warum
nicht mit putin wünschten sie sich so
etwas
also viele ukraine würden sich wünschen
dass der auslöser dieses krieges dass er
nicht mehr in der lage ist diesen krieg
fortzusetzen wie das zu ende geht liegt
in gottes hand aber für uns ist wichtig
dass diese präzisionswaffen die wir
gesehen haben gerade in kabul dieses
einsatz kamen dass auch wir ukraine
diese warfen benötigen denn nur auf
diese weise kann man auch den russen
zeigen dass sie nicht mehr zu holen
haben das ihren grenzen eine kopf
antwort das herz sagt auch gegen putin
ich glaube die die die waffen sind da
und die die amerikaner sind ja keine
kriegspartei sie wollten noch keine
kriegspartei werden das ist der punkt
also das heißt
dass dieses instrument sollte in
ukrainische hand liegen und wenn das der
fall sein wird und deswegen hoffen wir
dass auch die amerikaner uns mit
ähnlichen waffen ausstatten das ist
möglich es gibt keine polit politischen
grenzen dafür oder bedenken und dann
wird sich zeigen was theoretisch umgang
danke für ihre antworten danke für ihren
besuch anderem ehning danke danke
[Musik]